welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston Spiderman across the spiderverse
completely redefines the Marvel
Multiverse not just within this animated
spider-verse corner of it but I would
say fix the broken or incomplete logic
of the live-action Marvel Cinematic
Universe as well if Marvel Studios could
just follow the example of what this
movie did right spoiler morning before I
continue but Spider-Man across the
spider-verse has an insanely ambitious
plot that both deepens and clarifies the
Multiverse logic that we've seen before
in the MCU picking up a lot of the loose
threads and broken pieces of the
Multiverse mumbo jumbo that we've heard
across the mcu's various titles over the
years and in doing so binds this
animated spider-verse closer than ever
to the live-action MCU so that really it
is now just one interconnected web that
came out of you yeah you can't do that
huh no using even similar imagery and
the exact same actors just from a
different perspective with different
terminology so let's break it down also
please watch my spiderverse videos over
on the Deep dive Channel and support me
with one of these Miles Morales
Multiverse style of shirts that you can
get at nerd riot.shots seriously I'm
gonna be wearing this until I am
bleeding from the armpits okay as you
watch across the spider-verse there are
some interesting nods to the MCU like in
the opening sequence Miguel O'Hara tells
Gwen Stacy don't even get me started on
Doctor Strange and a little nerd back on
Earth 1999.99 it was Doctor Strange 1999
has been the past Universal designation
of the live-action MCU so Miguel is
telling us he is aware of doctor strange
and Tom Holland Peter Barker tampering
with the Multiverse in the events of
Spider-Man no way home a movie that you
might remember included both the Tobey
Maguire Peter Parker and the Andrew
Garfield Peter Parker then later in this
movie in the spider Society headquarters
Margo cast spider bite shows miles the
imprisoned multiversal anomalies from
across the Multiverse including a
live-action Cameo by Donald Glover as
Aaron Davis Prowler he tells miles it's
rude to stare and he later yells Boo as
miles runs past him holy a live
action actor in the same room as a bunch
of animated characters this is some real
hoovering Roger Rabbit Mary Poppins
and I'm here for it now you
might remember Donald Glover played
Aaron Davis in the 22 17 MCU Spider-Man
homecoming film but he was not yet the
prowler with any kind of suit like this
he also cameo in the 2018 into the
spider-verse on TV in the scene from
NBC's Community when he played Troy
wearing Spider-Man pajamas now it's not
yet clear if Donald Glover Aaron Davis
in this movie is the same as the one
from the MCU in homecoming but it is
possible because several years have
passed since the events of Spider-Man
Homecoming in the MCU if Miguel had
referenced the events of no way home in
the same movie and in homecoming Aaron
Davis mentioned having a nephew who
lived in the area whom he called miles
in a deleted scene yeah sorry miles I'm
not going to make it so this one Cameo
is a huge deal it signals to us that
within the MCU that same miles may be
the one who gets established in Canon
very soon additionally when the spot
Joyrides the Multiverse he stops at Miss
Chen's Bodega from Venom and Venom Let
There Be Carnage what do you want I'm
robbing you because I'm a bad guy now
it's interesting this movie labels this
universe Earth 688 meaning it's also a
codified part of this vast spiderverse
which you may remember also connected to
the MCU you from the post-credit scenes
of Venom Let There Be Carnage and
Spider-Man no way home there is still a
Venom symbiote crawling somewhere around
the MCU so all this brings us to the big
scene with Miguel O'Hara where he
explains the Multiverse from his
perspective he projects a web of red
lasers and he says this here this is all
of us all of our Lives woven together in
a beautiful Web of Life and Destiny the
web of life and Destiny in the Marvel
Comics is the name of the cosmic force
that connects all spider things together
but here miles gasps the spider verse
Miguel responds the spider verse that's
stupid and then he says there are no
humanoid poly Multiverse but he admits
that sounds pretty stupid too now for a
brief moment here there is a separate
projection showing the web of life and
Destiny as a white snaking Vine with
branches it's the same exact imagery of
a sacred timeline in the Multiverse that
the MCU has used in Loki and then in the
post-credits scene of Ant-Man that was
quantumania with the King Dynasty this
was Miguel's way of showing all of
existence but specifically for spider
people they're connected by these
angular webs with nodes miles asks about
these and these nodes were the lines
converge and Miguel explains they are
the Canon the chapters that are part of
every spider's story every time some
good some bad some very bad he offers an
example this one event ASM 90 a police
captain close to Spider-Man dies saving
a kid from collapsing Rubble during a
battle with an arch nemesis now the cam
vent number is reference to The Amazing
Spider-Man issue number 90 from 1970
when Spider-Man's battle with Doc Ock
leads to the death of George Stacy
Quinn's father and we actually see panel
art from that exact comic another note
also shows Andrew Garfield Peter Parker
crying over Captain Stacy's body from
the 2012 Amazing Spider-Man film same
Captain Stacy I'm so sorry and a little
later on there's a node showing Toby
Maguire's Peter Parker crying over the
body of Cliff Roberts and Uncle Ben from
the 2002 Sam Remy Spiderman film so if
those are connected to the MCU from
Spider-Man no way home because those
Peters reference these past tragedies by
the mathematical associative property so
too is this universe connected to it
geology is a 22-time award-winning skin
hair and body care company recognizing
Men's Health Oprah daily hypebeast
birdie Esquire and GQ their products are
built around just a handful of powerful
proven ingredients that have been
trusted by dermatologists for decades
just take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz geology will create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
customized just for you geologists
co-wash and their deodorant are just so
great and I use them all the time right
now they're offering a special offer for
a skincare sampler pack and geology
skincare stuff is in a league of its own
geology's line of skin care products can
help you fight acne reduce oil-ness
prevent wrinkles combat dark or puffy
under eyes have smoother hydrated skin
and Target signs of aging there's never
been a better time to try geology than
right now for limited time use code
rockstars100 to get 100 off your
personalized 30-day skincare sampler set
all you have to cover is the 495 for
shipping what a deal on top of that new
Rockstar spans get an exclusive bonus
offer of up to 50 off on an additional
skin hair and body product of your
Choice when you add it to your trial
click the link in the description or go
to
g-e-o-l-o-g dot i e slash rockstars100
to get started Miguel continues to
explain Canon events are the connections
that bind our lives together he later
says break enough Canon save enough
captains and we could lose everything so
can an event seem to be with the
animated Sony spider versus calling what
an episode of Marvel Studios what if
called absolute points fixed inevitable
plot points in a character's destiny
that cannot be bypassed without
threatening the fabric of existence for
Doctor Strange in that Universe it was
the death of Christine Palmer and across
the spider-verse one of many examples
was the death of Inspector Singh in
Earth 50101 the father two Privateer
private cards girlfriend who was
supposed to die in a button but miles
saved him he disrupted that Canon event
it's worth noting that in the case of
that episode of what if the doctor
strange episode when reality began to
erode it also did so in the medium of
oozing Black Ink as it does in this
movie now this isn't to be confused with
Nexus events in the MCU which the Loki
series defined as a turning point in
history from which a branch timeline
diverges another interesting wrinkle to
all this is the way the spider verse
apparently looks at gig Jonah Jameson JK
Simmons play Jay jonette both in the
same rhyming Trilogy and in the MCU Tom
Holland Trilogy contradicting what seems
to be a rule in many other cases that
each Universe has different actors
playing the characters even though the
movies do make some exceptions to that
like with Patrick Stewart playing
Charles Xavier in multiple universes but
in this movie anytime we hear Jay Jonah
Jameson it is the voice of JK Simmons we
actually hear it a couple times like
first in Miles Morales Universe Earth
1610 during an early recap montage and
then later in the Lego Universe
designated Earth 13122 they sample his
exact audio from the 2002 film tomorrow
morning Spider-Man page one with a
decent picture this time but other than
Miguel referring to the little nerd in
Earth 199999 we don't get a Tom Holland
Peter Parker cameo in this movie but
Genki Lee does refer to himself as miles
guy in the chair as Ned Leets does in
the MCU films to Peter Parker despite
its name Ned with Jacob battle on
playing the character is definitely
based on Genki Lee from The Ultimate
Comics but the fact that Miguel O'Hara's
Tech displays the Multiverse with the
same branching sacred timeline imagery
that we saw in Loki in Quantum media
tells us that his technology from the
year 2099 in Nueva York is starting to
tap into the tech that Nathaniel
Richards will master in the 31st Century
which yes is 900 years later but this
shows that Miguel can at least observe a
piece of it and he knows enough about
how the web of life and Destiny works
for spider people to try to maintain a
proper flow of Canon and I think this is
a testament to the arachno frequency all
spider people share a stronger awareness
and appreciation of one's variance that
allows spider people to cooperate and
share resources at a faster rate than
variants of other individuals like it
took Loki and Sylvie a few episodes to
get along with each other even then
Sylvie still stabbed him in the back and
Kang despite his cooperation all the
gangs ended up at war with each other
but the peters and all the other spider
people seem to inherently at least
diverse trust each other as a result of
their shared tragedies
let me guess he died so this would mean
as the MCU steers toward events like
Secret Wars this spider Society or any
team up of spider people is going to be
especially important to bridging gaps in
the Multiverse teaching other
individuals how to trust each other how
to operate and how to defeat multiversal
threats like Kang and now that Amy
Pascal is confirmed this week that we
will get a live action Miles Morales
movie I think this guarantees that miles
is going to show up in the same world of
Tom Holland Peter Parker and at the
nephew Donald Glover referred to in
homecoming will finally get paid off a
reminder to subscribe to our new channel
the Deep dive you can support us for
grab it's a merch like this Multiverse
dive shirt at nerdright.shop follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign